I'm Jeff McFerrin and this is Beastie
Boys story Illustrated I started
collaborating with the Beastie Boys
around 1996 when I became the art
director or grand Royal magazine as a
fan of the Beastie Boys and working with
them on and off for 25 years think it
gives me like a broad perspective of
this band that I have so much respect
for in making these posters I was really
interested in focusing on the Beastie
Boys creativity in their work and I feel
like using the iPad was a great tool to
just spontaneously create a very quick
way the sketches that I did that my iPad
to begin the project was like well can I
do one drawing that captures anything to
do with the spirit of the Beastie Boys I
wanted to have a moshing in the circle
the instruments are gone they picked up
the mics so this is using the
physicality of the guys and turned it
into some sort of like hieroglyphic
language explaining like the energy for
time but then the thing I added like the
end was this mobius nightcore it's a
reference to the smile the way that you
recorded the music like all laughing the
same lines and then like bouncing back
and forth but it's also like Beastie
Boys as one entity this is the check
your head era the shop of the Beastie
Boys not just with microphones but with
instruments this poster was them at
their most abstract but sort of passing
this shadow it like they were and is
outsize influence on the world of like
making this music that was so visceral
and maybe more familiar you felt like
you came out of my friend's parents
basement it just look like skater guys
the the wonky sort of anonymity of that
but a lot of way they're attached which
is sort of it in all the posters there
one that's melted together
the sabotage video was seismic when this
video came out with this like powerful
piece of culture that came out of the BC
boys but it was it was also spiked these
two groups people at their best they
made themselves icon they soar
disappeared into these like caricatures
and since I've primarily caught this
Caprice Tron ship from memory that it
phase it becomes a cop car this is one
poster that got a ton of movement which
i think is funny cuz in this era
costumes attending it to sort of play
and i think that aspect of being a fan
that of both serious and full attitude
but at the same time it's like the
longest game of dress-up ever played you
know in front of millions
I sort of made it speaking about the DC
boys our actives like one unit just
robot costume each of them have a part
of it the master behind it a cliff maker
and then Mike D with one big foot and
this giant Aukerman and you know they're
telling it none of its really
functioning you see as I evolved this
post went from them just sort of
standing there to like what made it
better was they gave little more
attitude and they started twisting their
arms there there's really yes don't
laugh of us you know but in the meantime
day in these ridiculous cardboard robot
costumes but they're still happy boy
we're the best son stuck to us five they
made something culturally that's even
more real than the real man you know
that culture goes on lives in a way more
than actually meant there's something
for think it's sort of important that I
want to capture in his last poster and
so that's that's why I wrote the title
for this actually before I did the
drawing which was a spiritual quest on
the front line of popular culture Mike D
is like the struggling is like coiled
energy about to go and then Adam
Horowitz is like always in the air to
like out wrap out b-boy everybody on the
block and then job is like on the wheel
life like he's much closer to the center
he's moved into the middle and he's just
his energy is like a spiritual energy
what sort of like funny about this event
was also sort of poignant because he's
also the one that we lost and so the
magic of it is also wrapped in a sort of
sadness there was so much of their like
artistic development that was done at
the zenith of
each one of these images is sort of
capturing the guys a bit like a physical
iconic truths about themselves
I draw so much the amount of time my
drawing takes makes a real difference
how much and I'm working on the iPad
like I could very quickly start to
sketch and come up with ideas to a
finished product
I think the busy boy story is so
relevant now they were making stuff for
each other you make culture that is most
relevant to the world right around which
most often it's your friends make work
pretty plans for me that's like the best
of culture like that's the stuff I love
[Music]